in 2001 Alejandro Toledo Rose to power
as Peru's first mestizo president a
champion of democracy a liberal
Economist he quelled a deadly political
Insurrection and finished his five-year
tenure with one-third of peruvians
supporting him he then moved to the
United States as corruption scandals
began to emerge Toledo denied any
wrongdoing
one just one piece of evidence just one
and I will be the first to step out of
politics
prosecutors accuse him of collusion and
money laundering for taking nearly 35
million dollars in bribes construction
Brazilian giant Olive bridge in exchange
for contracts in public works
it is one of the most solid cases in
judiciary the route of the money starts
from other brex accounts into the
accounts for late friend and partner
then to accompany Costa Rica that money
then brought a five million dollar home
and an office in Peru
tradition to produce since 2018 arguing
he was politically persecuted a victim
of racism for his indigenous Heritage
his defense sued the state department to
stop the process but it was unsuccessful
Toledo was a great success story a shoe
shine boy from a poor Village in the
Andes who reached the presidency but
political allies and followers say
Toledo deceived and betrayed them
the one who comes from the bottom and
carries out the dream of being able to
grow and reach the top and betrays the
essence the fact that a person like him
who represented the hope of Peru to move
forward has been mocked because so many
people believe deeply in what he
represented and at least waited for him
to live up to those hopes and of course
he did not
now he will face up to 20 years in
prison
will remain during the trial jail is
Cared by 4
as nearly all of Peru's former
presidents are under investigation or
jailed for corruption this facility is
expanding if they're convicted they will
likely also end up here with Alejandro
Toledo as its latest tenant Mariana
Sanchez
and Mariana is that Jorge javez
International Chavez rather
International Airport in kayawa the
former president landed so first of all
what happened to him now
well Sami he is still here at the base
at police base next to uh the commercial
airport this is where he's been for more
than three hours now since he landed in
in Lima after fighting Expedition for
such a long time now we saw an ambulance
go in and come out an ambulance with uh
with doctors who were supposed to uh to
check out his health he says his health
is frail he's all there's also been uh
the presence of prosecutors the top
prosecutor in the countryside was here
she's the one who supervises all of uh
the corruption case against former
president Alejandro Toledo and after
this it is still unclear whether he will
be taken to a criminal court or he will
just be flown out of here to the police
base that is about an hour away from
here that is
that is where former presidents uh
Alberto fujimori and Pedro Castillo are
at right now uh they are imprisoned
there
Alberta serving a 25-year sentence
waiting for the investigation on
corruption charges that's where Toledo
will remain
despite that his lawyer and despite that
he has asked the Peruvian Judiciary to
allow him to stay under house arrest
like Pedro Pablo kuchinski the former
president who is also under
investigation for corruption but he was
throughout his time he didn't go to jail
he was under house arrest he wants the
same because he says that uh that prison
will kill him as as he said in an
interview before turning himself in in
California Sammy all right thanks so
much Mariana there